brandon had to do problems 45 through 75
for homework tonight if brandon did all
of the problems he was assigned how many
problems did he do
so there's a temptation here to just say
well what is 75 minus 45 so you might
say hey 75 minus 45 is equal to 30 maybe
he did exactly 30 problems but we have
to be very very very careful here and to
understand why we have to be careful
here so let me put a question mark right
over here to and to to realize why we
have to be careful here is imagine let's
do some smaller numbers so that we can
really count things out so let's say
instead of 45 through 75 let's say he
had to do problems let's say he had to
do problems three
through
6.
if we use this technique that we just
did up here we would say well 6 minus 3
is equal to 3 maybe he had to do 3
problems let's actually count it out so
there's problem 1 problem two problem
three problem four problem five problem
six so he did he's going to have to do
problem three through six including
problem three so he's gonna do problem
three problem four problem five problem
six when i subtract six minus three i'm
really only caring about problems four
five and six i'm looking at how much do
i have to go to go from three to six i'm
not including the actual three so really
when he's doing problems three through
six he's not just doing six minus three
he's doing six minus three
plus one
plus one he's actually doing four
problems he's actually doing four
problems and you can do this with
multiple scenarios to realize when you
just subtract you're not counting you're
not counting the very first problem
you're just counting all the incremental
ones after that so to answer this
question if he's doing problems 30 45
through 75 it's not enough just to
subtract that won't count the first
problem the 45th you actually have to
add one so in this case brandon does 31
does 31 problems let's do another
counting problem
a baker has a whole loaf of bread how
many cuts must he make to have exactly
seven even slices well you could work
this one out directly try trying to cut
a slice of bread but let's think about
even if there were 70 even slices a much
larger number well we could do
we could do a little loaf of bread so
that's our loaf of bread
if you want two slices
two slices
how many cuts do you make well you only
make one cut
two slices you only make one cut
what if you wanted three slices
so if you wanted three slices
how many cuts do you need to make well
you make one cut and you make two cuts
so you make two cuts
and i think you see a pattern here if we
want four slices
four slices how many cuts do we make
well one
two
three cuts so it's three cuts and you
could go all the way to seven but you
see the pattern however many slices you
want you only need to do that many
slices minus one cuts so for seven even
slices you only have to do you only have
to do six cuts and you see why you don't
have to cut you don't have to cut out
that very last piece it just falls off
the edge
let's do
let's do one more of these
e sean is building a straight fence with
posts one meter apart if the fence is 18
meters long how many fence poses does he
need
well we'll use the same the same idea
let's do it with a smaller situation
let's imagine a
let's imagine a two meter long fence
for two meter long fence he's going to
have one fence post then the fence is
going to go a meter the fence is going
to go a meter then he's going to need
another fence post then the fence is
going to go a meter and then he needs
another fence post so if you compare it
to the cutting bread you kind of have
your cut but you also have to do the
ends right over here so for a two meter
fence he needs three
three posts what about for a three meter
fence
for a three meter fence well you're
going to have to have the first post you
go a meter of fencing
then you have the second post
meter of fencing you have the third post
but you're not done yet then you have
another meter of fencing and then you
need to have the end post right over
here so you see you need four
you need four posts you essentially need
one post at the beginning of each
section
and then you need one to finish up so
what you see here is however meters
you're going to need that many plus one
posts so here if you're going 18 meters
you're going to need 19
fence posts